The vital ingredient for stiffness is that the model includes to vary different time scales.
That's not the case for this spacecraft and that's not the case for the 1D harmonic oscillator.
But with the cloth simulation, we do have to vary different time scales.
Imagine this cloth to be composed of tons of tiny, tiny springs.
This is actually how cloth simulation is being done.
If you push the cloth in this direction, you're working against the stiff spring,
meaning you're working on a very small time scale.
If you push the cloth up, you're rotating that spring, meaning you're working on a slow time scale.
This is a very annoying problem for the simulation of pieces of clothing,
in video games, and for special effects in movies.
You do not want to use time steps of microseconds for something that seems so simple.